bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
Laurent Hubert j'ai 42 ans et je
participe aujourd'hui au challenge des
créateur pour le prix de l'insertion
j'ai créé mon entreprise il y a tout
juste 11 mois donc en novembre de
l'année dernière et je suis de formation
esthéticien praticien formé bien-être
j'ai ouvert mon entreprise donc mon s
d'esthétique art bioessence institut à
saintcloutil sur la route du bois de nef
j'ai travaillé pendant 14 années dans le
monde du spa donc au niveau de
l'hôtellerie suite à cela j'ai travaillé
6 ans dans l'industrie pharmaceutique le
bien-être et le monde de
l'esthétique également le monde du spa
était toujours été toujours été ma
passion en fait et euh donc comme j'ai
failli perdre mon mon dernier emploi
j'ai saisi cette opportunité pour
justement ben concrétiser mon rêve
c'est-à-dire créer ma propre STR
structure le but pour moi c'est
valoriser les métiers qui sont
généralement occupés par un monde de
femme donc aujourd'hui mon but c'est je
suis la preuve bon ben c'est-à-dire en
tant que homme ben j'ai réussi à à me
faire à me faire une place aussi bien
dans le métier aussi bien en en ayant la
confiance
de mes
clientes je m'appelle francisc lomba mon
entreprise c'est acte-toi action
ancienne bien donc acte-toi à toi d'agir
et je fais le développement de talent
dans mon métier c'est exécutif coaching
j'ai fait comme le coach en sport le
coaching pour des affaires donc
j'accompagne les décideurs et des
managers et des chefs entreprise pour
qu'il puissent transformer leur contrat
en opportunité pour qu'il puisse
rébondir et être meilleur là où il
veulent avancer pour gérer l'entreprise
au mieux et qu'on vient le changement et
s'épanuir donc développeur de talents
Jack Brell a dit le talent nexiste pas
le talent c'est avoir envie de faire des
choses donc j'essaie de donner aux gens
l'envie de trouver qu'est-ce que leur
fait envie de chercher la pépite qui est
dans chacun donc ce qui est la petite
graine qu'on peut faire pousser
j'apporte de l'eau du soleil et je fais
pousser les talents qu'on a en soi pour
justement avoir un management plus
humain plus vers le sens pour donner aux
gens envie de faire ce qui sont censés
de faire mais avec un vrai connaissement
pour atteindre la haute
performance bonjour je m'appelle chefard
desvis donc j'ai 20 ans euh moi je suis
euh spécialisé dans la décoration de
salle avec ballon c'est un concept
encore peu connu ici à la Réunion donc
c'est l'argument qui nous a poussé à
ouvrir nous ce qu'on ce qu'on a apporté
donc dans ce domaine c'est euh notre
produit F qu'on a lancé en 2014
à savoir le centre de table avec ballon
la première année était un peu difficile
parce que la pume n'est pas
essentiellement accessible donc on a
trouvé des alternatives en sollicitant
des artistes pour la publication de
notre page
facebook pour que ça touche un maximum
de personnes et c'est vraiment sur ces
réseaux sociaux qu'on récolle la
majorité de nos contrats on s'adresse à
tous les acteurs économiques de la
Réunion donc les ménages les futurs
mariés les comités d'entreprise donc
tout ce qu'il a qui qui fait référence à
la fête donc pour les gens qui aiment
une décoration originale autre que les
décorations de table donc on vient au
complément justement de cette déco et
l'on travaille en partenariat avec des
décoratrices quand on regarde tous ces
jeunes qui trim pour chercher un boulot
ou tous ces patrons qui font la sour
d'oreille donc c'est ce qui nous pousse
à ouvrir notre propre entreprise on sait
les difficultés on est jeune peut-être
mais on a vraiment une maturité qui qui
nous est propre et qui nous pousse
justement à saisir ses responsabilités
et à grandir face à ses
responsabilités